.
BUT NOW MAKE OR MISS, YOU HAVE
TO BE READY TO SLOW SOMEBODY
DOWN.
YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO GET THIS
BALL TO A GUARD WITH HIS
SHOULDERS HEADED TOWARD
HALF-COURT IF YOU CAN.
IT LOOKS LIKE ARIZONA IS
THINKING ABOUT LEANING UP AND
JUST WATCH OUT FOR THE BASEBALL
PASS IF YOUR ARIZONA.
>> Rich: BALLO MAKES IT.
TWO-POINT LEAD.
THREE SECONDS LEFT.
NO TIMEOUTS.
NEAL IN BALANCE.
CAMBRIDGE.
OH!
HE GOT IT!
HE WON IT!
ARIZONA STATE HAS DONE IT!
>> Jim: MY GOODNESS.
>> Rich: DESMOND CAMB
CAMBRIDGE JR.!
THE SUN DEVILS HAVE TAKEN DOWN
NEVER 7!
NUMBER 7!
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Jim: UNIDO PRAYER IN THAT
SITUATION.
PRAYERS WERE ANSWERED.
HE GOT THE BALL IN THE RIGHT
SPOT.
TURNING UP TOWARDS HALF-COURT,
GIVING HIM SOME MOMENTUM TO
CARRY THE BALL TOWARDS THE RIM.
HERE WE GO.
HE ROLLS, GOES UP THE FLOOR,
SHOT UP IN THE AIR.
FORGET ABOUT THE CLOCK.
THAT BALL IS GOOD.
>> Rich: LOOK AT BOBBY HURLEY
IN THE SHOT.
>> Jim: THAT HAD EYES FROM THE
TIME HE LET IT GO.
>> Rich: THEY HAVE LOST TEN OF
THEIR LAST 11 ON THIS FLOOR.
>> Jim: DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
MISSING A FREE THROW TOO.
>> Rich: FOR A BUBBLE TEAM,
THIS IS LIKE A QUAD ONE SQUARED
WIN, RIGHT?
YOUR REBEL, NUMBER 7 IN THE
COUNTRY, AND ARIZONA STATE AT
11-7.
>> Jim: IT'S AN ATTENTION
GETTER ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
>> Rich: DESMOND CAMBRIDGE JR.
HEAVE.
HE WINS IT.
FOR JIM SPANARKEL,
GENE STERATORE, I AM RICH WALTZ.
SO LONG FROM TUCSON.
SUN DEVILS WIN.
COMING UP, AUBURN AND KENTUCKY.
THIS A PRESENTATION OF